the protagonist of today's story
discovered ancient tombs explored secret
passages inside pyramids and recovered
artifacts as old as time itself and he
did all of this while also getting into
fistfights foiling assassination
attempts with his trusty whip dodging
bullets amongst Egyptian ruins and
facing the opposition of a French rival
now this point it might sound rather
familiar to you but no we're not talking
about Indiana Jones
we don't do fictional characters here on
biographic swell we sometimes do but
we're pretty sly about it nope today's
video is about Giovanni Battista belzoni
the Italian circus strongman adventurer
Explorer Tomb Raider early archaeologist
and the father of modern Egyptology
[Music]
Giovanni Battista belzoni was born
giovanni battista ball zone on the 5th
of november 1778 in Padua northern Italy
back then a part of the independent
Republic of Venice all we know his
family is that his father was a barber
and that he shared a home with 13
siblings he displayed signs of rebellion
and lust for adventure at a very early
age he was 13 when B rebelled against
his father's wishes that he apprenticed
as a bother
and he ran away from home dragging with
him his younger brother of just 9 what
was their objective
well that was to reach Rome the Eternal
City
after days of endless walking they
finally got there or so they thought
they were actually in Bologna 400
kilometers north of Rome definitely not
a bad start for someone who would become
famous for being an explorer Giovanni or
gia batter as his brother used to call
him he did not surrender three years
later with the help of an aristocratic
friends he finally made it to Rome yes
at last and then his dreams came true
because he became a barber I mean
there's nothing wrong with barbers don't
get me wrong I don't mean any disrespect
but it's not exactly what he wanted to
do in fact that's
kind of why he left in the first place
so Jia bata at this point had started to
show an interest in the new science of
hydraulic engineering but he did not
have the occasion to put this into
practice yet then at the age of 18 his
girlfriend she loves him his totally
rational and measured reaction to this
was to take religious vows and become a
Capuchin friar it was with the monks
that he first put into practice his love
of hydraulics by building wells and
irrigation systems for the convent Jia
bata at a restless soul and he soon had
outgrown the convent life quite
literally he had become a giant of six
foot seven or about two meters and he
was almost as wide and as strong as an
ox this was just not really very
credible as a contemplative monk but
good news is history came to the rescue
because Napoleon entered Rome in 1798
and dissolved all religious orders Jia
wata had the chance to join the French
army that he sided with the Prussians
instead
whilst traveling Europe with the
Prussian army gia bata realized that he
was very popular at country fairs
because of his size and people they were
willing to pay to see him he also had
perfected his hydraulic skills creating
small shows with musical fountains and
magic lanterns at some points in the
early 1800s he had left the army and he
made his way to the Netherlands and he
funded his travels with his shows it was
after one of these shows that he added a
slight misunderstanding with some French
soldiers the details are not known
except that G about the Giants
apparently battered the soldiers that
meant he had to flee to the only place
in Europe when a Poland's armies
couldn't reach him and that was of
course Great Britain the first thing gia
bata did was change his surname from
Bull's own to belzoni you see this lad
he also had brains the surname Bulls own
sounded suspiciously Spanish to
untrained English ears and Spain was an
ally of Napoleon at the time then he had
to ensure a livelihood for himself and
for his newly wedded bride Sarah his
engineering skills but not appreciated
so gia bata put into place Plan B in
1803 he became a circus strongman with
the name of the Patagonian Samson he
later became known as the Roman Hercules
the highlight of his show was the human
pyramid
during this act belzoni would walk
around the stage carrying 12 grown men
on his back then sarah would climb up
onto the top of the pyramid waving a
crimson flag
other acts included juggling flags while
carrying seven men or lifting a cannon
by its muzzle the show also included a
performance of musical glasses and a
magic lantern display proving that this
giant had more intellectual ambitions
than it transpired Belle's only became
very popular and he and Sarah started
touring circuses and theaters all across
Europe from Edinburgh to Madrid from
Lisbon to Naples it was during one of
these travels that his life was going to
change direction once again
[Music]
in February of 1815 Belle journey and
his wife they were sailing back from
Naples when their ship was forced to
dock in Malta Napoleon had just fled
from his exile in Elba in the British
Navy and the Mediterranean was
inspecting all suspicious vessels it was
in Malta that Belle Jolie met by total
chance one mr. Baggesen
envy of Muhammad Ali Pasha the Viceroy
of Egypt Muhammad Ali was one of those
characters who treat life like an
all-you-can-eat buffet of Albanian
origin he travelled to Egypt in 1801 to
fight against Napoleon with his band of
mercenaries he had quickly risen through
the ranks becoming Viceroy in Cairo
formally subordinate to the Ottoman
Sultan in Istanbul berths in fact the
true ruler of the country doing as he
pleased including keeping a vast harem
of wives and concubines and siring
ninety-five children in addition to
single-handedly contributing to the
demographic growth of Egypt the Pasha
was also concerned with growing its
economy he had undertaken a vast
modernization programme of Egypt's
agriculture focusing on cash crops like
cotton and tobacco that required complex
irrigation systems so as you might
imagine hydraulic experts were somewhat
in high demand
well journey it was at this time a
successful showman but the lure of his
first love
hydraulics it was irresistible he jumped
to the occasion and sold his services to
Backhouse claiming that he had designed
an irrigation wheel six times as
efficient as the ones currently in use
in the spring of 1815 well journey his
wife Sarah and a young Irish assistant
called James curtain they landed in
Cairo Cairo and all of Egypt at that
time was a dangerous place even if the
Pasha welcome to Europeans they were not
seen favorably by the majority of the
population and that included the ruling
elite they were suspicious and rightly
so of their colonial ambitions so two
nations were particularly active in the
Egyptian theater Great Britain and
France their aim was to extend their
influence over the Pasha and the
country's economy but most of all it was
to raid as many ancient Egyptian
artifacts as possible to meet the
demands of museums and private
collectors back home
the paschal welcomed belt Czerny with
open arms but the giant found out that
his will was not intended to raise the
waters of the mighty Nile to irrigate
the desert its aim was simply to feed
the fountains adorning Viceroy Horan the
wheel did work six times better as
promised but during its inauguration a
prank by some of the courtiers resulted
in it almost crushing bells oneis
assistant James Curtain it was almost
the final curtain for curtain when the
Italian lept into the canal and thanks
to his enormous strength he stopped the
wheel just in time the wheel
unfortunately it broke down marking the
ends of belzoni hydraulic career in
Egypt so well what now
Mohammed Ali took pity on belzoni and
his wife and introduced them to the
British consul Sir Henry salt salt had
been tasked by the crown to collect
statues sarcophagi and other pieces to
replenish the Egyptian collection at the
British Museum which at that time was
lagging behind that of their mortal
rivals the Louvre museum in Paris salts
counterpart in the French Camp was
consul Bernardin or draw vetti born in
turin in northern italy draw vetti had
fought alongside napoleon against the
hated Austrians his military prowess had
earned him a french citizenship and
given him a taste for the use of
explosives muskets and the services of
cutthroats now I should clarify at this
point that neither of these guys nor
their employees were archeologists let
alone Egyptologists these were just
glorified tomb raiders and art thieves
with little respects or knowledge of the
culture that they were plundering Henry
salts was looking for a strong and a
resolute man who could succeed where
drove Ettie had failed he wanted someone
to collect a giant bust of the pharaoh
ramses ii from the ruins of ancient
Thebes in southern egypt he then wanted
that loaded onto a boat on the Nile and
transported to Cairo
the French consoles had even drilled a
hole into the king's head loaded it with
explosives and tried to blow it apart
into two pieces so that it was easier to
carry it didn't work and the statue it
remained intact
[Music]
salt gave belzoni
a very detailed set of instructions for
his recovery mission the last of these
instructions was don't drop it in the
nile belzoni could not wait to face the
stone giants and he left the Thebes
immediately he soon realized that the
only way to shift the 9 foot tall 7 ton
heavy statue across five miles of sands
was to use the same technology used by
the ancient Egyptians
a wooden sled ropes and sheep later now
it wasn't known tactic employed by
Trivedi that he would send his agents to
stir dissent among the locals to hinder
his rivals efforts this may explain why
during the first days of the thebes
expedition some of bells oneis hired
workers they turned against him the
leaders of the rebels attacked him with
a dagger the italian giant he coolly
disarmed them knocked them out cold and
lifted them by their ankles and swung
them around in order to inflict blows on
the other attackers now it's important
we point out that we have by graphics we
don't endorse this as a method of
resolving trade disputes but we have to
admit that as far as self-defense goes
pretty badass
the rebellion it was quelled and after
three weeks of hard work ramses ii
gigantic head was sailing down river
towards cairo it did not drop in the
nile and escorted by the great belzoni
the bust made it all the way back to
england ramasees the seconds head it
still sits today at the British Museum
in the summer of 1817 belzoni was back
in Egypt's now heading for his second
expedition to unearth the legendary
temple of Abu Simbel the colossal
structure at the time was almost
completely buried in sands with just one
head poking out of the sand belt Vernie
was escorted by two British Navy
officers James Irby and Charles Mangal
these two were not really interested in
ancient Egyptian architecture they had
joined with the hope of doing what every
British gentleman of that time was
expected to do get into a firefight with
the French the party did not have to
face Trivette either but rather a giant
dune covering the temples entrance after
six weeks of constant digging under the
fierce summer Sun on the 1st of August
1817 for three Europeans and the local
laborers finally entered one of the
grandest temples of ancient times the
first humans to do so in more than 3,000
years belzoni found out that the were no
jewels mummies or statues to be seized
but he did not leave completely
empty-handed he drafted a detailed map
of the temple noting all measurements
and proportions of note this is the
detail that set him apart from other
grave robbers he had a desire to acquire
knowledge and understands the art and
architecture of the ancient Egyptian
civilization
but they also had to make a living so he
returned to Thebes to look for more
statues on behalf of salt and the
British Museum when he got there he was
met by a bad surprise the site had been
taken over by a party of French diggers
belzoni who was well known to them and
he knew he better avoid them but he was
spotted Reddy's men had firearms and so
is forced to flee during the chase
through the ruins of Thebes one of the
French fired his pistol narrowly missing
the giant man the Italian wrote to
consult Henry salt in Cairo things they
were getting dangerous for him and as an
agent of his Majesty's consular services
he had every right to demand armed
protection
the thieves chase was not the only
instance in which belzoni had reason to
fear for his life once in the port of
Alexandria he had been approached by
drew vetti's interpreter a fellow
Italian who had told him in pair terms
if I see you around one of our sights
I'll slit your throat in another
occasion belzoni was riding through the
streets of cairo when he was
aggressively confronted by an egyptian
officer demanding passage through an
alley the officer did not wait for an
answer and delivered a blow to belzoni
stomach the giant a simply did not
flinch not being accustomed to put up
with such situations I returned the
compliment and struck him with my whip
across his shoulders the officer then
took his pistol and shot at belzoni but
the Italian dodged the bullet and it
went on to hit another soldier who was
approaching him from behind
during a later exploration to the oasis
of alka saw his two local guides tried
to kill belzoni in his sleep once again
he was quick to reactant strangled the
two assassins in self-defense and it's
at this point that we have to wonder did
these people really see no risk in
attacking a 6 foot 7 inch strong man I
mean there are risks involved with such
an endeavor but anyway belzoni he didn't
always have the upper hand in yet
another mission he had collected a
monumental obelisk from the island of
Falah on the Nile near aswan but all of
his hard work was to be in vain as
vetti's men seize the obelisk by holding
the giant at gunpoint
[Music]
and now let's go back to meld zonies
message to souls in August of 1817 this
is when salt laid out his carts in reply
he specified that belzoni had not been
employed officially by the British
governments or the British Museum salt
considered him to be his own private
employee little more than a mercenary
this made a big difference it made
belzoni disposable and his findings were
private property insults hands the
Italian was not happy but he continued
his travels away from the dangers of
Thieves his next target well that was
the legendary Valley of the Kings where
he made some initial interesting
discoveries however at this time
hieroglyphs had not yet been deciphered
so in fact he didn't really have any
idea what he had discovered as an
example he once stumbled into the tomb
of King Ibis only noted a wall painting
of twelve baboons therefore he called it
over tomb of the 12 monkeys now grace of
movement as he might imagine was
definitely not his forte by his own
confession when leading arrest inside
the same tomb I sought a resting place
and contrived to sit but when my wage
bore on the body of an Egyptian it
crushed it like a bandbox I sunk among
the broken mummies with a crash of bones
rags and wooden cases every step I took
I crushed a mummy in some part or other
so yes in just a few moments he
essentially destroyed a museum's worth
of concepts as another example another
time the Italian came across an ancient
wall and ordered his workmen to open a
passage using a sophisticated scientific
instrument a battering ram his
experience in the Valley of the Kings
was not all slapstick however following
hints from local legends on the 6th of
October 1817 he made his greatest
discovery so far the entrance to the
tomb of Seti the first a richly
decorated sprawling burial site the size
of Sint Paul's Cathedral in London the
monument is still also known as Bell's
oneis tomb and was described as the
Sistine Chapel of ancient Egypt when
news reached Cairo and result organized
a tour of the site with a group of
British aristocrats who looked down on
Belt Zoni as a simple hired hand this
was the end of the collaboration between
the two men but only realized that salt
had been
in credit for his achievements with the
British establishment not only vast the
console had failed to ship many of
builds only specimens to the British
Museum and had been selling them at
private auctions instead the Italian
rescinded his contract with salt and
continued working on his own adding
another string of explorations under his
belt and then on the 2nd of March 1818
was his last great achievement having
visited the pyramids at giza belzoni
became fascinated with the pyramid of
Heffron this was the second largest
pyramid and it was generally recognized
as being inaccessible following a hunch
the Italian found a secret entrance on
the north side of the building and
crawling inside it he came across a
burial chamber and toured its
subterranean section to avoid having his
discovery appropriated by various salt
he quickly scrawled on a wall discovered
by G belzoni 2nd of March 1818 that in
Italian it was like this
by 1820 after five years of adventures
Belle journey and Sara were back in
London being a showman to the core of
the giant organized a spectacular live
dissection of a mummy for the Royal
College of Surgeons and an exhibition of
Egyptian antiquities in Piccadilly both
were very popular
his main endeavor was to set the record
straight with salt and claim the credit
that was due for his discoveries he
wrote an account of his adventure
entitled narratives of the operations
and recent discoveries within the
pyramids temples
tombs and excavations in Egypt and Nubia
and of a journey to the coast of the Red
Sea in search of the ancient Baroness
and another to the Oasis of Jupiter
Ammon by giovanni battista belzoni in
two volumes we're going to assume that
the first one there is the title the
enormously long title the book it had
some success however it seems that salt
eventually won this duel of Fame until
recently most of Belzer knees recovered
artifacts at the British Museum were
still known as the salt collection
in the spring of 1823 belzoni left
London for another adventure this time
he was in search of the source of the
river Niger in West Africa and of the
lost city of Timbuktu in modern-day Mali
the Italian was forced to take a long
detour VAR SI because of a local war
raging in southern Morocco and so in
November of 1823 he landed in Benin with
a British merchant John Huston it was
here that belzoni met his ultimate foe
ironically for such a giant it was a
tiny creature that would succeed where
cutthroats and French bullets had failed
belzoni contracted dysentery a bacterial
infection of the boughs highly prevalent
in tropical areas which in severe cases
may cause death by dehydration and this
was one of those cases feeling death
creeping in the once mighty Roman
Hercules entrusted an amethyst to his
companion for it to be given to his wife
on the 3rd of December 1823 giovanni
battista belzoni died and was buried
under a tree in guava Benin
[Music]
belzoni is considered by part of the
archaeological community as a thief and
an ignorant vandal others though they
celebrate him as an adventurous
character who laid the foundations for
modern Egyptology many even see him as a
source of inspiration even as a certain
inspiration perhaps for a Raider of the
Lost Ark at least according to some film
critics we know where we stand on that
one but we'd love to hear your views on
the protagonist of today's video please
do leave your comments below and as
always like and subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]